unser klima steckt in einer handfesten
krise dass wir etwas tun müssen ist fast
jedem klar
aber genug wird nach meinung von qualys
verfügte noch nicht getan
deswegen ruft ihr morgen am freitag zu
einem zweiten globalen klima streik auf
vor einem jahr ungefähr ein bisschen
mehr hat ihr euren ersten was hat sich
in diesem jahr bewegt und was fordert
ihr noch genau genommen ist es sogar der
sechste globale klima streik jetzt ist
es hier hatten wir vier dieses jahr
hatten wir im april seinen corona
version im netz
und jetzt gehen wir das erste mal seit
corona wieder richtig auf die straße wir
rufen auf weltweit
die entscheidung muss uns überhaupt
nicht leicht gefallen denn es ist eine
wahnsinnige herausforderung und
belastung für alle beteiligten sind aber
gezwungen durch die anhaltende korans
mit der die klimakrise kritisch
behandelt wird und durch steigende
emissionen weltweit und damit auch durch
die steigende gefahr für menschen
überall auf der erde insbesondere in
bedrohten region und in zukünftigen
generationen durch die klimakrise und
damit auch die forderung klar wir
fordern von der regierung weltweit auch
in deutschland dass ihr abkommen was sie
selbst verhandelt haben das pariser
abkommen einhalten und alles dafür tun
um das in die wege zu leiten um es
umzusetzen und das natürlich gerecht
nachhaltig und wirkungsvoll aber eben um
so das mindeste zu tun was man tun muss
um die lebensgrundlagen der menschen zu
bewahren und ganz direkt neben menschen
vor der unvorstellbaren leid zu befahren
bewahren wovon wir auch schon heute
sehen wir das aussehen könnte wir müssen
gar nicht weit gucken um zu sehen wie
die klimakrise aussieht nun war zum
beispiel deinem kollegen jacob blasl der
war auch lange zeit aktiv bei freilich
verfügt diese forderungen waren ihm
nicht genug und deswegen ist ja jetzt
bei freiem fuß und in die politik
gewechselt er es bei den grünen
eingetreten und darauf dass ein im
bundestag gewählt wird
du bist schon lange mitglied bei den
grünen könntest du dir auch eine
politische karriere so vorstellen oder
könnte freude ist future einer partei
werden
naja was wir sehen ist dass keine
demokratische partei im bundestag
derzeit eine 1,5 grad politik klar und
umsetzt oder konzipiert und was wir
nicht brauchen oder was
das zentrales was es braucht ist sein
eine demokratische mehrheit im parlament
die bereit ist dass paris abkommen
umzusetzen und das muss überparteilich
passieren also es brauch in allen
parteien an demokratischen parteien war
es ein kino bewusstsein und ein
verständnis für diese herausforderung
und einen ganz konkreten planen das ist
was wir einfordern was wir sehen ist
dass dieses wirksamste mittel was es
gibt und die größte hoffnung die wir
haben ist sind die menschen auf der
straße die menschen aus der gesellschaft
die begleitet von wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftlern zusammen diese art von
politik einfordern das ist wo ich mich
sehe das ist wo wir in den letzten zwei
jahren bewiesen haben dass entscheidende
hebel da liegen und da werden wir weiter
druck aufbauen also eine politische
karriere wie jakob wäre nichts für dich
ich sehe mich gerade war der wirtschaft
der straße wir brauchen in jeder partei
menschen die politik dann auch umsetzen
können die die klimakrise verstehen und
im politischen geschehen handeln und
gleichzeitig sehen wir eben dass ohne
den druck auf der straße dort nichts
läuft
das ist waren wir morgen auf die straße
gehen und das ist was ich mache mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur weil
bild schau dich jedes nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren